You have to really try and see where
you can identify need.
This is marketing was all about.
It's about identifying the needs
and finding the right product
to match those needs.
Shirley Segal,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good morning.
Thank you.
And thank you for having me.
It's a pleasure to have you.
We're calling from a sunny morning
here in Tel Aviv, but actually,
it's not your preferred weather.
You mentioned to me
that your preferred weather
for some really weird reason
is foggy rain?
I don't know.
I'm a broken Israeli I think.
Probably my soul was born somewhere
in the prairies of Poland.
I like the drizzling.
I like it where it's nice and gloomy.
That's where I'm happiest.
But I'm born here.
So, I go along with the flow.
What can I do.
So, you're going to have to go along
with the beautiful weather
and the beautiful sun
that goes on the beach.
But it's okay.
Because today,
we're talking about your journey.
We're talking about
being a marketing director
at various companies.
Very, very well known in Israel.
All the way from Bezeq
to Cellcom to Zap,
companies that really marketing
is part of their core,
ideation and innovation.
We know how difficult
the market is in Israel,
so, I'm excited
to talk about that.
But I'm also excited to talk about
your experience with the 8200
International Alumni Community
and how that relates back
to serving in the 8200 units.
So, Shirley, take me back.
How do you start your journey
out of 8200?
What is sort of like
your thinking process as you go along?
Oh, I was
in a very traditional thinking process.
Okay, I need to go to the university,
Tel Aviv University, the best university,
the best place, because I'm  8200
and that's where we went.
And I think the click happened
during Marketing 101.
And the MBA
of business administration
in the Tel Aviv University,
it was like falling in love.
Suddenly the way
I understood about how to influence,
how to understand
and influence people's behavior,
that was where I found myself
in my natural element.
I remember distinctly I said,
"Oh, this is what I want to do."
And from that point on,
my aim was to go
to the best places in Israel
and later on international.
To the best places
where the marketing challenges,
the one that will actually blow my mind.
So, started up
for one of the Bezeq companies.
But actually Cellcom,
I think was probably the one
that really formed
my marketing personality.
Because Cellcom, at the time
was a company for the big numbers.
And this is marketing for me.
This is the real challenge in marketing.
It's taking a whole world of numbers
and trying to find  the story behind them.
And not only try and find
the story behind them,
make your story so that it works.
So, this is like sound like Lit 101.
No, but it's marketing 101.
So, whether it starts
with huge excels files,
Arpo and Age,
you have to really try and see where,
where you can identify needs.
This is marketing was all about.
It's about identifying the needs
and finding the right product
to match those needs.
And funnily enough, those needs
will appear on Excel sheets.
They will also appear on focus groups.
And something that little people know
but it will also appear
when you talk to colleagues.
And we had some
of the greatest success stories,
coming out not from focus groups
and not from talking to customers,
and that's from looking
at the Excel sheet.
But it was this, how about if
we did this first plan
and know it will work.
We ran that with surveys.
We ran that with focus group.
Everybody says it won't work
and it works like a charm.
Because sometimes,
it's about good intuition
and believing in something that's logical
and going with it all the way.
Sometimes your customers
are not believing.
They go for the pay as you go
and you say: okay, let's try packages,
or say: no, we don't work packages.
But when the packages come
and are offered to them,
they go for packages.
So, you just have to try.
A lot of the time
you just have to try
and know that you're going to fail,
sometimes miserably,
but you just have to try
and give it a good try
every once in a while.
Go against everything.
Everybody says and try a new concept.
Because this not only benefits
the organization,
it also benefits yourself.
You know that sometimes
you have to try something new.
You go against the flow.
Fail and sometimes
you get great success
and you understand that
it's not always about harvesting it
from the Excels and from the customers,
it's also about finding the ideas
that will generate later on
good growth options.
100%.
Yeah.
And I have to ask because
in Cellcom, one of the incredible
positions that you've held,
which is fascinating to me,
is customer retention, right?
And I know from living in Israel
how competitive this industry is.
So, can you tell me a little bit about Cellcom
and what was really
your position going into this role,
which is incredibly,
incredibly difficult,
incredibly competitive?
So, tell me a little bit about
what it was like.
So, it was not only the greatest
the better part I think,
of working the marketing,
of being in charge of retention.
But the timing was
an unbelievably amazing timing
because at the time,
the minister of communication
cancelled the living fees.
So, actually there were no barriers
into moving from one company
to the other.
And if this has happened,
I think in about two or three months,
we knew it was coming.
We didn't believe it was coming.
We prepared ourselves.
But once it came,
it started an unbelievably
fierce war price between
the companies because suddenly,
there were no barriers
to leaving any companies.
You had the number,
there were no fines,
hallelujah.
And in I think in two months,
the prices dropped in 200, 300%
And the term was unbelievable.
And add new MVNOs,
going into the game
and they had nothing to lose.
Again, for all they know,
they can name a price tag of 19 shekels,
which is like, I don't know,
six, eight dollars and they'll gain.
And also the regulatory procedures
allow them, really encourage them
to add as many subscribers
as they can until such a time
where if they have this amount,
they'll be able to go further.
So, everything was laid out
to good, healthy, unbelievable price war.
And this happened overnight.
And what you do is you form
what you say,
you form a war room
which convenes every day at 12.
You have to look at the numbers.
You have to identify
where you get the most journaled out
and what are you going to do in return.
And Cellcom is a big company.
At the time it was 5,000, seven.
A very large company.
And, you know, the large companies
are not in the habit
of working very fast.
But this was, I think,
a defining moment for Cellcom,
because you actually saw
how a very large company
working very slowly
and very methodically
can convene at 12 PM
and decide that
this is a price plan
that will give the best solution.
And by five o'clock,
You have the price plan in place
after going all through
so many people and development
and you have the price plan in place
and you're ready
for 8 AM next day to launch it.
This is how things
should happen everywhere.
And this is where I go.
And this is where, personally,
I get the kick out of.
You know, I said that in Cellcom,
the best thing that
you came around 8 AM,
you said, okay, I need to do this,
that this is how I do it.
But by 11, and always,
11 AM was a magic moment.
Something happened.
Something happened that you went,
Oh, no. What am I doing next?
And you had to really
make a handstand
and forget everything you wanted
to do by that point
and try and do something else
just to match reality.
Unbelievable.
So, this was that period.
And it was an awesome period, really.
So much adrenaline.
So much excitement.
Really working around the clock.
But really, this is a magic moment
for any company
and for every professional
where you actually feel
that you have no limits.
And things you thought
that cannot be done can be done.
Everything can be done.
If can just put your mind to it.
100%.
Yeah.
And from that point on,
the loyalty policy actually changed
180 degrees.
Because up to that point,
we've had big loyalty programs
and large campaigns
and great benefits.
And it was all about
surprise and delight.
You know, now you have
this amazing benefit
and you can take out
all your friends out for breakfast
on our expense,
or you can buy books
for very low prices.
That was the policy
up to that point.
And the policy
from that point onward,
because it was obvious
that people no longer
found it interesting, they said,
okay, just give me the best price.
And let me be.
Don't call me.
Don't give me benefits.
I'm not interested.
Just give me the best price.
Because that was what energized
the market at that point.
Right.
And from that point on,
it was a lot about the service,
the ongoing service
and the ongoing relationship between
the subscriber,
the customer and ourselves.
It was about bringing values
of being very honest, very outgoing.
The saying Hebrew shakuf, transparency.
And that was a value
that became very important
during that time.
I'm Sure.
No more you know,
complicated price plans,
no more services, add-on services.
Being very transparent
to our subscribers,
create one magic word,
which is trust.
100%.
And that's where you get loyalty.
I think that just phenomenal.
Yeah.
And that's a challenge.
I have to ask you because
I'm fascinated also
by your work with Zap.
I love Zap.
It's a group that has three subgroups
that you were in charge of also
their marketing.
Rest.co.il, Mishlohim and Mitchatnim.
And so tell me what lessons
did you bring with you
from Cellcom and Bezeq
as you're transitioning
to be director of marketing
for these very different companies?
Right?
They're not the same.
It's not the same customer experience.
It's not always the same customers.
So, what lessons did you bring in
and what new challenges
did you have to face?
Yes.
So, that was actually the Israeli yelp.
The challenge there,
it's always about
the marketing challenge.
And the marketing challenge there
was actually going both ways.
It's a B2B challenge because
you work, the advertisers
are small, medium businesses in Israel,
which I knew very well from my time
working in Cellcom and Bezeq.
But also, it's the Israeli crowd.
You have to please the people
that will eventually coming to rest,
coming to deliveries,
coming to the wedding website.
So, it's a double side challenge.
And this is the part where
I can talk for hours and hours.
But it's also about finding
how everything into meet,
finding how I give the,
the people who come to the website
a definite value.
And we did that actually in Rest first
and then onwards for Mishlohim
by personalization.
And you think personalization
it's so obvious,
but to check a website,
that was just a restaurant website
with ratings and nice pictures
and making it into a website
that actually, when you come in,
Michael, and when I come in,
we see two different websites.
You get the recommendations for you,
you get the content
that will match your needs.
And I get that different content,
different recommendations.
And by adding personalization
into these websites,
we actually prove the win-win situation.
More surface came in,
a lot more surface came in,
the website SEO went up the roof
and our advertisers were happy.
Because not only
we brought more traffic,
we brought more relevant
traffic for them.
And when you ask
what connects
Zap group, and you know,
the Israeli Yelp and Cellcom,
it's about identifying the needs.
It's always about that.
Identifying the needs
and talking to the customers
and really understanding
what makes everybody ticks
and going on from there,
developing the product that would
best suit everybody's needs.
And also for me, it's technology.
So, I'm a big fan
of everything that's techie.
And really, when you see
the last 20 years
and what technology brought in
for marketing,
this is a small time revolution.
Because we went on
from starting out
from just having surveys
and measuring traffic
into really having concise insights
into the buyer persona
and having immediate,
which is awesome immediate feedback
about how campaigns are going.
And not going into one big campaign,
but going into 20, 30,
sometimes 100 micro campaigns
and just optimizing as we go
and seeing what works best for us.
So, this is also one thing in common.
It's technology
and how you can use it
to be a better marketer
and to develop better products
and making your customers happy,
which is the basic
for every loyal customer.
Right.
I think what I'm taking away
from this is primarily,
really the art behind marketing
and really the perspective
of really understanding
what makes people tick
and really what they're looking for
and forming this relationship,
not just with your customers,
but forming this relationship with
what you're marketing,
and the product that you're using,
that you're using to market because
that relationship it sounds
that you have to really be transparent
and honest with it
in order for it to come out authentic
and to really gain
the loyalty and trust of the customers.
Shirley, 20 minutes go by so fast.
And I want to thank you for being
so generous with your time.
It's unbelievable.
But we do have
the most important question.
We have the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. So, disclaimer,
I did think about it ahead of time.
Curious.
First thing is curious,
I'm impossible
on the bordering of really going
into every detail, people.
That's the most interesting thing.
You should know,
you know, how many interviews
have you had so far, over 200.
That's the most interesting thing,
talking to people
and learning things that are on YouTube.
So curious, energetic.
I think it came across, you know.
Bring it all.
I love being in good dynamic places.
And the last thing
that I'm very hands on,
you know, I really like
to get my hands dirty.
I will always be the one who goes,
oh, let me handle that.
Because you do learn things
by your own experience.
Don't go too far away from
where everything happens.
Get your hands dirty.
Because that's where you really learn.
I love it.
Shirley, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
Best of luck
with your continuing great work
with marketing direction.
And thank you for the inspiration
over these past 20 minutes.
Thank you very much.
Have a good one.
Bye bye.